[Music]
we've heard the headlines
playing lots of video games can lead to
poor mental health
i have to be presentable on the news but
according to a new study for young
people like darcy
who is playing animal crossing the most
popular game of 2020 there are more
benefits
to her mental health researchers found
those wandering through this fantasy
world for long periods of time
tend to report feeling happier than
those who do not
if you're stressed and you have lots of
stuff on your mind like
oh i have homework lots of homework
due in tomorrow or or what if my friends
don't like me because i
played with someone else or anything
like that
you could just go into something on
nintendo and it it's so
calm and it's just relaxing and
you can even it's just amazing
and it's really good for your mental
health
the gaming industry has seen record
sales in recent months
as more people are told to stay at home
there are thousands of games featuring
gigantic worlds
that allow people like simon to meet
others online
it's a great way to stay in touch with
people anyway but to do so even if
they're just living down the street from
you
i just think it's a connection to
normality and at the same time you can
make it a social experience too
over 3 000 gamers were asked how they
felt about their experiences playing
nintendo's animal crossing
which allows you to escape into a
perfect paradise populated by weird
animals
and ea's planets versus zombies so why
is the science telling us these games
are actually good for our mental health
in both of these games um when people
felt socially connected
and they felt a sense of choice and
volition in the play so it was like a
i don't know a digital water cooler um
they were much more likely to report uh
positive well-being and so
the real question is you know how might
we uh understand something like socially
connecting in a violent video game is
that possible
uh and what are the broader uh societal
impacts
of course not everyone sees video games
as an outlet for depression or anxiety
but during these challenging times
they've become more than just a
distraction
no phillips sky news